dieser wahltag war ein misserfolg er
muss wiederholt werden sagt fdp ein
experte stefan thum mehr ganz herzlich
willkommen bei bild ja warum soll der
denn wiederholt werden der tag der
nächstes jahr gibt es doch den nächsten
jahr und veredelt natürlich muss man
einräumen dass dieser versuch mit dem
wahlsystem nina und waren fehlgeschlagen
ist
das sollte ja genau dazu dient mal zu
testen wo wir mit diesen serien ersatz
weiterkommen und natürlich funktioniert
ein solches waren sie nur dann gut wenn
es sekundengenau punktgenau aktiviert
werden kann genau das hat hier nicht
funktioniert das jedoch einräumen
es war ein fehlschlag und deswegen
sollte man schnellstmöglich an arbeiten
das ist ebenso intakt zu setzen dass es
auch jederzeit eingesetzt werden kann
auch schneller als noch in einem jahr
und deswegen wird dafür schnell wieder
zu beseitigen und den wald noch mal zu
wiederholen oder sind vielleicht apps
dann doch nicht der richtige weg um
wirklich die bevölkerung zu warnen
sollten die sirenen vielleicht
angeschafft werden weil wir alle wissen
wie naja man sich nicht unbedingt aufs
mobile netz ja verlassen kann gerade in
entlegeneren gebieten gerade eine
katastrophe kann es mal passieren dass
man sich in funk schatten befindet oder
dass die systeme ausfallen
deswegen ist auch natürlich eine immer
ist und weil nur so gut ist wie sie auch
angewandt wird das heißt also die
menschen müssten jetzt auch installieren
müssen sie aktivieren müssen auch
erreichbare nähe eines einer funkzelle
sich befinden im aktiviert werden kann
anderes modell wäre zum beispiel per sms
zu arbeiten zu wissen dass wenn sie
irgendwo eine grenze fahren nachricht
erhalten dass jetzt im gebiet eines
neuen anbieters sich befinden
diese sms kann man also so programmieren
dass sie in jedem fall erreicht aber
auch da kommt es darauf an ob sie so gar
nicht den flug modus aktiviert haben und
er semester sich gesandt werden kann
viele systeme syrien sind ein system es
kann gründe geben nicht auf serien
vertraut sobald einer großen stadt wie
berlin oder wie hamburg oder münchen
kann das nicht passieren dass eine
sirene überall gehört der ganzen stadt
aber eine bestimmte situation nur ein
stadtteil betrifft und sie ist ehrlich
immer sehr ungenau so gibt nur einen
baden ton von sich werden sie mit einer
sms oder eine app nachricht genau sagen
was ist basiert wie sollen die menschen
verhalten
jetzt kennen wir dieses system der
bundesweiten landesweiten warnung der
bevölkerung ja nach aus zeiten des
kalten krieges vor der wende da gab es
das einmal pro woche dass die sirenen
geheult haben warum ist es wieder
wichtig solch ein system zu installieren
die welt wird wohl der adler wird
verwundbarer unsere gesellschaft wird
komplexer auch die wirtschaft und
erleben sie jetzt weil das in einer
pandemischen situation wir zu maßnahmen
gezwungen sind wir uns früher nicht so
hätten vorstellen können aber auch
internationale terror bedroht unser land
in der stärke aber auch er natürlich
gruppen die bei uns im inland agieren
das heißt wir sollten uns vor augen
halten dass wir nicht zu unverwundbar zu
sicher sind wie wir das früher
vielleicht gedacht haben sondern die
gefahren
neben er zu gewalt nicht sicherer und
deswegen sollte man sich auch wieder
mehr mit fragen des bevölkerungs
untersucht das beschäftigt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaue ich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren